all right hi everyone thank you for the
introduction Michael
any for being here today and I'm going
to be talking about any social computing
so social media has brought us closer
together provide social support and can
improve our mood it has been used for
social good think about things like ALS
icebucketchallenge
used to self-organize such as during the
Arab Spring but however in recent years
what's becoming clear is that there is a
dark side to social media and social
computing trolling online harassment and
misinformation increasingly prevalent in
many online platforms today and even
before the recent u.s. presidential
elections maybe I really thinking about
what's going wrong with social media why
are there so many holes in online
discussions why do I sometimes do unsafe
when posting things online and why is
there so much misinformation isn't just
a feeling
antisocial behaviors commonplace recent
study by data in society found that
almost half of users have been harassed
in one way or another being called
offensive names physically threatened or
sexually harassed and you know that any
social behavior is a problem whereas the
many popular websites are so overrun by
the trolls that they have just decided
to completely turn off the ability for
anyone to comment so it's social media
getting out of hand and our online
community is getting worse over time and
are we actually witnessing an epidemic
of that behavior so ultimately you want
to build better healthier online
communities to combat any social
behavior and there's several ways to do
this we can create better guidelines for
online conduct design better
interventions as well as develop better
systems to combat such behavior but to
do this first and foremost me to
understand what's going on today and so
what do we really know about antisocial
behavior about trolling
so prior wealth has largely
characterized trolls as a small vocal
minority and that antisocial behavior is
due to sociopaths
so in research using primarily
qualitative methods including surveys
and interviews the trolls come across
largely as this group of people they're
very different from most of us for
example taking immense pleasure in
others misfortune and other work has a
trolls as having unique psychological
profiles being more Makaveli on all
statistic but running and being innate
and the domain of sociopaths my won't
show us in antisocial behavior trolling
can be situational and then ordinary
people can be driven to troll given the
previous view of trolling might have
concluded that simply removing the bad
actors would make all our problems go
away
but if trolling is instead situational
we need a different perspective and we
need a different set of questions to
understand what's going on and what we
can do about it so here are three
questions I'm going to try to answer in
this talk so first we're going to look
at why trolling occurs or the causes of
any social behavior and how anyone might
become a troll next we'll look at how a
new social behavior might worsen over
time and even spread from one person to
another and last we'll take a bird's eye
view of any social behavior and
spreading behavior more generally and
look at cascades in the view can't be
predicted so how this is done is through
complimenting data mining with
crowdsourcing can use the other mining
to find generalizable insights and then
combine this with the use of
crowdsourcing which enables on
experimentation they can then establish
causal links and more broadly it is what
really seeks to identify the principles
of human behavior in the large social
systems that we use today which you can
then draw on to design better ones and
to do this use data mining machine
learning study large amounts of data and
make predictions network science to
understand the structure of these online
interactions and then HCI human-computer
interaction to design with design
experiment with and build these social
platforms so that was the big picture
and now let's dive in and start with the
causes of any social behavior and ask if
anyone can become a troll so the far
continue as a heads up some of the
examples of antisocial behavior in this
talk may contain strong and offensive
language so in this work we study any
social behavior in the context of public
commenting platforms such as on CNN so
here's an article on CNN from a few
years back it talks about how women
perceive them
also online and here are some of the
actual comments on this article so
here's one pretty insensitive comment
I'm not going to read them out and if
that wasn't good enough for you here are
the reply to that comment right so
there's some name-calling the some
sarcasm and then it's mostly not very
constructive to understand these
instances of anti-social behavior like
what I just showed you in collaboration
we've discussed we analyzed the do set
consisting of multiple large commenting
communities the insight realized
comprised of a turbine of complete data
over a year of activity from 76 million
users who made a total of 470 million
posts and 831 million votes but before
we can alight rolling create a working
definition of what trolling is so here
are four different definitions of
trolling is it engaging negative mark
line behavior is it not following the
rules is it taking pleasure in upsetting
others or is it disrupting a group while
staying undercover and a lot of these
definitions make sense in different
contexts right some abroad some on there
or a more specific summon code intent
and some do not
and maybe your preconceptions of what a
troll is and your experiences may speak
to even other definitions and in this
book while we're actually interested in
lies closer to bad behavior in general
and so we take inspiration from some of
these broader definitions and the find
trolling as behavior that occurs outside
of community norms and so under this
definition regardless of intent trolling
happens as long as people are seem to
behave like trolls and why this is nice
is that the Community Guidelines for
many websites are pretty similar no
name-calling no personal attacks no
automatic material and so on and by
looking at how moderators moderate these
communities using these guidelines can I
use this as signals to automatically
identify instances trolling so while
these trolls exists again we don't
really know very much about who's
responsible for this bad behavior and
its prior work as well as these
headlines above suggest the media
portrays trolls as this group of misfits
there are definitely not any of us in
this room right now
hope but is this really the case what
can locate all data tell us so for
instance if trolling is an eight-hour
trolls just trolling more often than not
you can report showing the distribution
of users who are banned from cnn.com
which you use as a proxy for trolling
and we might imagine that if these
trolls are inherently bad that they are
most if not all their posts deleted by
moderators but well many of these
supposed rules have all their posts
leader the sizable numbers have a much
smaller proportion of posted leader as
well in other words the tribution of
trolls or people were banned is bimodal
and so could these two peaks correspond
to two different types of anti-social
behavior that goes on so maybe the
people who are writing bad things all
the time are these lifelong regular
trolls models who only have a small
fraction of their posting do it maybe
they're just having a bad day all right
and importantly because we're looking at
ban users only this is going to
underestimate the population of
situational trolling and so because of
this observation now we start to
reconsider all assumptions that maybe
trolls are not just a vocal minority
so rather than trolling being mostly you
name what is anti-social behavior was
actually a lot more situational and but
again how are we going to go about
showing whether this is true or not
right you can make observations with
data but it's hard to demonstrate
exactly what causes trolling and if we
did run an experiment the same thing
might be am i and kind of different
issue that it won't generalize so what I
did was to combine both right you can
done all experiments simulating a
discussion as well as Carol an
observational study of an actual
discussion community and so while the
experiment helps us establish causality
Aldina analysis lets us demonstrate that
these findings can be replicated and
that they generalize so now I'm going to
claim that any anyone can become a troll
and usually expert use evidence from
experiments and data I'm going to show
you how it's possible to induce people
Patrol and what I'm going to do so by
drawing on theory from social psychology
the first of which is the broken windows
theory and this theory suggests that
norms can strongly signal whether for
the bad behavior happens one
since that broken windows signal that
crime was acceptable in the neighborhood
the second theory concerns how long has
a stimuli aversives increase aggression
one study showed how exposure to
secondhand smoke increase a person's
aggression towards unrelated others and
still again a lot of this prior work was
conducted several decades ago the
absence of all interactions and under
different circumstances so could this
actually translate to trolling online so
to begin we first conduct an experiment
on Mechanical Turk that simulated a
discussion forum and the general
structure of the experiment was as
follows we had participants take a quiz
then head and participate in an online
discussion and so while very necessary
conditions we then ran many identical
discussions in parallel to observe how
participants behavior changed in this
experiment we used a two-by-two
between-subjects vectorial design and we
modified difficulty of the quiz and thus
both initial discussion context so
drawing on theories of aggression we
varied a difficulty with a quiz to
influence participants mood and drawing
on the broken windows theory we vary by
the discussion context was good or bad
so what does this quiz look like the
quiz that we asked participants to do
looks like this and it had 15 questions
there showing you a small part of that
version the positive mood condition like
you see here was calibrated to be pretty
easy so that participants with a high
scores and maybe feel good about
themselves
the other virtue of the quiz was
substantially more difficult and
designed so that most participants would
score poorly and in this version we told
participants that needed poliana test
anyway regardless of how you're actually
performing and last these participants
also had five minutes to answer all 15
questions so good luck with that so
after completing this test we then had
participants take part in a discussion
about event upcoming u.s. presidential
elections so some context this
experiment was done during the 2016
Democratic primaries where people are
deciding whether to jewelry Clinton or
Bernie Sanders as a Democratic Party's
presidential candidate so in the
positive discussion context condition we
see that these discussion
is initially more positive what sorry
not more neutral and constructive
comments such as these and a negative
discussion context condition these see
comments were more negative and I did
not make any of these comments up so
what happened so first as a manipulation
check for mood using a post quiz
validated we questioned it you saw that
people were in a much worse mood after
the hard quiz than the easy quiz people
to go out much worse scores in the hard
quiz as well and second as a check for
discussion context we also found that
the initial seat posts in the negative
discussion context condition will
perceive worse as well do only 36% of
voted compared to those in the positive
context condition which will 90%
uploaded so now until main results so
how much trolling was there in each
condition so here we had two expert
raters labeled post is trolling or not
blind to condition you can stand the
Community Guidelines
such as from cnn.com and we then measure
what proportion of post me in each
condition watch all posts so
participants when the positive mood and
content condition all that they saw the
easy quiz our discussion without any
initial trolling through adult rolling
was lowest at 35% and so this number
might really look a bit high but also
remember his participants were
commenting on a relatively controversial
topic at the time so people got the
difficult quiz always showing troll
posts previously the rate of trolling
increases in both cases by a similar
amount and the people got both the
difficult quiz and will show intro polls
this is that too almost twice the
incidence of trolling we test the
significance of these results using
mixed effects was just a regression
model and find that both main effects
are significant and that there are no
significant interaction effects
analyzing all data a different way can
use Luke as well to measure the
proportion negative emotion words as a
proxy for trolling behavior and we find
similar trend here P well the proportion
of negative emotion words almost
tripling in the worst condition as
compared to the base classes condition
and to give you a sense of what
participants actually wrote here are two
examples so here's one comment from the
good condition so when participants
easy quiz and we're showing usual
comments like this majority of them are
pretty reasonable on the other hand when
people in a bad mood and/or had seen
prior to a post they wrote things like
this so in other words bad mood and
negative discussion context increased
trolling but you might also know ask or
maybe say that this is just a lab
experiment right and these results may
not hold up in the real world so we also
analyze an actual discussion community
cnn.com to see we could try to replicate
these findings so turning to data here's
what we found in relation to both food
and discussion context so now we can't
study move directly we can study it
scarlet so for example prior will
measured how mu tends to swing the time
of day and day of week and follow
remarkably stable patterns in how
negative effect autumn of negative words
used on Twitter changes of time so we
can observe similar trends with regard
to indicators of trolling that would be
highly suggestive of we were also
influencing trolling so here's a part of
the time of day on the x-axis and the
proportional flag post on the y-axis and
what we find here is that the post made
in the morning is much less likely to be
slide for abuse than one made in the
evening right and what's nice about this
is that this matches Golda's and Macy's
findings about how negative effect
changes with the time of day similarly
they also changes based on the work week
so post flagging or trolling is highest
at the beginning of the work week on
Mondays and decreases as we near the
weekend like today or tomorrow and we
did not just observe this for the
proportion of flag posts
so across multiple indicators of
trolling trolling increases at the times
of day and days a week where people are
in were smooth you also find an anger
can lead to more anger so just as we
found that doing poorly on the quiz
effective later commenting and
discussion negative mood spills over
from prior discussions in two subsequent
unrelated ones so the shoulders we look
at a discussion with at least one flag
post and selected the user ghost flag
and user walking at random
and so that we weren't selecting people
who are ready tools we ensure that both
users never had any of the prior post
flagged or do need it now when each user
goes on to post in a separate discussion
we then compare the likelihood of that
future post being flagged as well and
what we find is that the user who was
previously flag was of the more likely
to be flagged and later discussion so in
other words to compare users who trolled
in a previous discussion of those who
did not
those that habitual were twice as likely
to troll this later unrelated discussion
so that was move now turning to the
discussion context we can also directly
replicate our experimental findings here
and show the initial post of the
discussion strongly affects the
subsequent likelihood of trolling so
here you compare two top-level
discussions in the same article where
one begins to a black post and one does
not you find in discussions that do
begin with a flight post are more likely
to have subsequent post blog as well and
here again the control for confounding
exclude the opie as well as users
flagged or deleted in the past and in
fact here initial troll post increases
the rate of trolling in subsequent posts
by 63% those contexts having established
factors really installing experiments
and in data as the next step can we
predict trolling or of a particular post
will will be a troll post before it
happens right so here we examine the
bounce data set about 120,000 posts
where a random guessing results in 50%
accuracy and then Trina logistic
regression classifier on the following
sets of features move discussion context
and user features you can measure mood
indirectly through flagging in
discussions a lot of diurnal changes and
you can measure context by looking at
their prior posts in the same discussion
so the third is basically indicated
variable for every user and these
features let us test the relative
importance of two hypotheses about
whether trolling is situational or if
trolling is innate and so here's what we
found
so we dressed we can identify calling
behavior by finding these suppose at
trolls we do kind of okay all right
getting about point six six AUC but when
looking at mood and context we can do
little better now move alone does do
worse but this is expected since can
never move directly but however
discussions context does outperform
using user specific features and showing
here the extrinsic factors such as
Russians context are more important than
these intrinsic uses specific features
in predict controlling and of course if
you combine both types of features you
can do even better predicting if a
subsequent post will be a troll post and
notably we can do this without looking
at the content of the posting question
so the summarize this first part you
might think about two factors that
influence a user to troll so first a
mood sets a baseline for how
susceptibility are the trolling and when
the user participates in the discussion
poster in my other users tend to provide
the sparkle in participate user and
directly result in them trolling or not
in filamentous section because trolling
is more situational than innate that
ordinary people can become a troll under
the right or wrong circumstances so but
now we might be also thinking like what
can we do to mitigate bad behavior so
cause loading be the answer to all
problems so vote expressed a lot of many
social media website to one part for
example being reddit the content behind
voting is simple the better content
should get more votes and that worse
content should get more downloads but
does this actually work in practice so
here's a different claim so it's not
fully helping to reduce that behavior we
claim that instead exacerbates the
problem because downloading can cause
negative behavior to worsen and so this
is the next question that we're going to
ask right how any social behavior might
worsen over time and in other words
because antisocial behavior spiral so in
this section we are going to look at the
role voting has and how people get from
bad to worse and as both essentially a
way for us to evaluate each other other
users content we subsequently describe
them as evaluations so here our goal is
to see how people might react not only
to negative but positive evaluations and
so that we can compare the differences
so what do we mean by a positive or
negative evaluation and again I did not
make any of these common
so so here is an actual comment that got
five out votes and four down votes and
together these numbers can help us
quantify how positive or negative and
evaluation is so this work we define a
positively evaluated posters one with a
proportional upload is greater than some
given threshold get a 75th percentile
post in terms of this proportion of
votes and similarly a negative evaluated
post is one where the proportion of
votes is lowered and some given
threshold to the 25th percentile so
given that the user receives a positive
or negative evaluation from other
members of the community how will that
use behavior change afterwards so theory
suggests that either could be possible
right operant conditioning says that
feedback would guide authors towards
better behavior so users would behave
better after getting either positive or
negative evaluation now that means that
you did well and the download means that
you didn't and should improve in the
future on the other hand bad is stronger
than good
that impressions are quicker to form and
more resistant to this confirmation and
as people have a much better memory for
when bad things happen there when good
things happen maybe this could be the
effect instead so which of this is
actually the stronger effect of the
tooth so to answer this question we
focus on four large commenting
communities some of which you might
recognize and the results I'll show here
apply to all of them so say we have two
users one positively evaluated and one
negative evaluated if you look at these
users posting histories one important
question we're going to ask is how
either users post I evaluated before or
after the middle positive or negative
evaluation but of course simply
comparing different users isn't going to
work because who's to say that users who
get downloaded are inherently worst
commenters and similarly a downloaded
comment might also get inherently worse
comment so how let me solve this so I do
can say is conducting observational
study using what's called propensity
score matching the general idea here is
that you want to match pairs of users so
that they are as similar as possible up
to the point of comparison and then see
what happens when they receive different
treatment
in our case positive or negative
evaluation and he report our findings
using PSM but using cmcm or course in
the exact matching also produces similar
findings so here again here are two
users one positively evaluated and one
negative feedback is it and of course
these two users and not going to writing
the same thing but you want to ensure
that they are so what we do is first
match pairs of users and text quality
which essentially turns text into a
comparable number but of course what on
earth is text quality so here's how we
compute it so I did here us create a
machine learning classifier they only
uses bigram text features of a post
content to learn the proportion of up
votes P that it received and we then
define the predicted proportion of up
votes as text quality Q of a post and we
obtain Q just by looking at the text of
each of these posts you have any concern
with bias in computing text quality
since the proportion of elbows is its
self biased my whole theory D doing
pretty well here by only using text ml
features and as initial check what we
did here was the crowdsource labels or
where the post was good or bad again
using these standard Community
Guidelines first up to the post where 10
crowd workers evaluated each post and
from this we can obtain Q prime or a
true label text quality and now the see
how good Q is compared to P we can then
correlate Q prime with both P and Q and
here's what we found so you find that
text quality's far more correlated with
the crowds guess than the actual
proportion of voters and what this is
saying is that text quality cues are
reasonable but nonetheless noisy
approximation of Q prime you can also
observe that the arrow between Q and Q
prime is the spirit relatively randomly
for different values of Q so there's no
systemic bias in the using Q and Q prime
so back to the problem so the match
pairs of users we first ensure that
these two posts have similar text
quality you're sort of control for the
length of the post and the number of
words right and we further make sure
that these users complete posting
histories or similar before this
positive and negative evaluation for
example ensuring that the other similar
number of posts and civil proportion of
votes on
in the past after controlling for these
factors we now have match two users
they're indistinguishable on our
mismatch covariance only that one
usually got a positive evaluation but
the other got a negative evaluation so
after controlling for these covariance
how then should we measure how the
subsequent posts are evaluated to answer
this question we also need to understand
what an evaluation is so essentially
there are two components to an
evaluation we evaluate something that
someone wrote both are something content
and the someone your preconceptions of
that person both affect these
evaluations that you give so in one hand
there are these textual effects or
technology or how well people write so
in other words was the post downloaded
because it was badly written the other
part of this are the community effects
of how the community perceives that
particular user the person get
downloaded regardless of what they post
because the community simply dislikes
them so let's start this look at the
first component these evaluations
relating to the text of a post
and ask you people write better or worse
after a positive or negative evaluation
having controlled for covariant such as
text quality prior so what we find here
is that using a wilcoxon signed-rank
test we find that post quality drops
significantly after negative evaluation
but not after a positive one and this is
true in all the communities that we
studied so this change after a negative
evaluation echoes findings on the
positive negative asymmetry effect from
social psychology the intuition here is
that you feel a lot worse after getting
a negative evaluation then after you get
a positive one so people write worse
after receiving negative evaluation
let's also look at how community
perception changes after these positive
and negative evaluations so for example
after receiving negative evaluation does
community perception worsen but of
course I haven't also showed you how
community bias is computed so for each
post no data set you have the number of
up votes number of down votes as well as
text following all scale to be between 0
& 1 and comparing the actual evaluations
with the predicted texts quality can
then see the community is
positively or negatively biased so once
we find what we find here is kind of a
halo effect post made up the negative
evaluation will worse than really
expect but on a scale positive
evaluation in other words the community
is predisposed to download you if you've
been downloaded in the past regardless
of what you write and on CNN your posts
are on average being evaluated over 30
percentage points worse then we'd be
predicted by text quality visualize I'll
be finding so far so sterile all of them
so say we have two posts by two users
one positively evaluated and one
negative evaluated the y-axis signifying
how positive something is first we
control for the text quality of these
two posts and then next we also ensure
that these two users that wrote these
posts EPS in the posting histories we
then look at what happens to text
quality after the positive and negative
evaluation planet-x quality drops after
negative evaluation but not after a
positive one if you further compare the
changes in community bias or the
perceptions of these posts we find a
perception worsens after negative
evaluation beyond what text quality
indicates so in summary here's what
happens negative the evaluated users so
not only do these negative evaluated
users write worse posts after these
posts are perceived worse by the
community and there is more bad news
so you'd hope that maybe negative
feedback discourages people from posting
but however people who are negative
evaluated I also won't likely to post
more frequently than those who are
positively evaluated and and to make
things even better or worse depending on
your perspective
they also more likely evaluate other
people's posts more negatively as well
so they retaliate to being downloaded by
downloading others as well so let's
update our model of trolling so moving
as well as context through what I
believe a write can cause people to
troll but beyond just writing
downloading can also make things worse
bad behavior can feed back into the
system as people get troll or downloaded
I'm all I needed : down with others
resulting in a negative spiral so what
this really means is that a
twelve might just have been a ordinary
user that got downloaded started to
write worse and be perceived worse and
then they now really recovered after
that so given that anti-social behavior
can spread from person to person on a
macro level can we actually observe this
downward spiral in these communities and
maybe we can so here's some food for
thought and a slide about how the
proportion of votes on cnn.com is
changing over time on the x-axis here is
from September 2012 all the 2013 if you
don't have newer data because CNN stop
having comments on this website and on
the X and the y-axis is the proportion
of up votes so we know that it starts
out higher but it's gradually decreasing
over time and if we leave so what this
says is that if we leave negative
behavior unchecked in the community it
can have far-reaching effects in the
long term and cause the community to
worsen over time and definitely here
more work needs to be done but overall
interesting to see how these microscopic
interactions between individuals may
translate into macroscopic observations
so at this point I talk about antisocial
behavior and how it might spread from
person to person I haven't talked about
what's going on at a macro level right
so how is bad behavior and bad
information spreading in these networks
and is that spread predictable so
popping up one level in this section I'm
going to explore what happens when bad
things cascade and so one related thing
here is that beyond bad behavior
something that's also been getting
attention recently is bad content
although generally rumors so rumors
don't only come in the form of faking
you so once in a while you see these
image memes make the rounds and you
might wonder why these things keep
appearing right and so when starting
these kind of image memes and these
rumors what we know this commonly is
that the same rumor can have wildly
differing levels of popularity here are
two examples of different people sharing
the exact same thing on Facebook and why
did one get no resoures and one got 416
and also what's worrying here is that
the one on the right I go 416 shares was
also the one where people call it all if
a so what is going on
all right so rather than focusing on the
rumor itself perhaps you can also learn
something from understanding underlying
network in which rumors
information and cakes news propagate and
so if you analyze the cascade that makes
up the spread of a rumor we can then ask
the broader question of whether these
cascades are predictable and we're
finding can then be applied to both
memory cascades as well as the spread of
other information cascades so for some
Paragon as to what a cascade is here's
the friendship Network if edges
connecting friends and suppose that I
share a rumor and maybe two of my
friends decide to share a rumor as well
two more people see this rumor share my
friends and share it with their friends
and as more and more people share in
this rumor a cascade is formed
highlighted here in green so but we want
to predict how a cascade grows there's
evidence that Cascades may be inherently
unpredictable and there are several
compelling reasons why this might be so
the first is that large cascades are
rare so shown here the distribution of
the size of reshare cascades on Facebook
and as you can see here the number of
cascades that grows large is vanishingly
small so less than 10 percent of
cascades reach a hundred or more
research because these large cascades
are so rare might be hard to predict
when they occur if they do at all and
past research also provides for evidence
so the famous music lab experiment
participants use a music ranking service
to rate songs and the goal is to see
which songs were come popular when the
experiment was repeated many times and
one study found was it was hard to
predict which songs would get popular in
each instance of the experiment so in
other words that increasing the strength
of social influence increase both
inequality and unpredictability of
success so this suggests they might be
difficult if not hopeless to predict if
something will become popular or a
cascade will grow large another thing
that makes cascade unpredictable is that
they can't die down and then resurface
I'll recur after a long period of time
so in contrast to prior work and plats
our intuitions what I want to show here
today is that Cascades are actually
predictable not only can we predict the
Cascades future size vary how its
structure will change how identical
pieces of content will be differentiated
and we can also predict if they Oklahoma
back from the dead
the task of formulating the prediction
problem predicting the growth of the
Cascade so given that we have seen some
number of research how should you
predict future growth so there's several
possibilities here maybe you could ask
the Cascade will get a large level
reshares maybe you could use regression
to predict how large a small cascade
will get perhaps you can only look at a
largest Cascades and each of these have
different problems there are issues in
terms of the size of each class the
distribution of data and how data was
selected how me instead formed a
prediction task that doesn't suffer from
these issues so what if we instead ask
if a caste will reach the median size by
definition the median splits the data
set 50/50 so we have a valve
classification task now you might ask
what is this medium f of K so plus more
intuitively question of whether a casco
reach the median size is equivalently a
question of whether it will double and
this follows because the size of a
cascade tends to follow up on
distribution with exponent 2 so it's
only this formally described this
cascade birth addiction problem we asked
given that a cascade has obtained KB
shares will it double in size and what's
good about this approach is that results
in the balanced prediction task and also
allows us to track growth over time as
by varying K so here the study cascading
behavior we sample the 70 million public
photos upload faceful result and five
billion tree shares and track V shares
of these photos for 28 days
following the initial upload and so we
looked at four different sets of
features content features like whether
it had overlay text not whether it look
like a meme
user features such as friend count and
gender note that structural features
like proximity to the root node or
outdegree
because these Cascades are basically
directed acyclic graphs so you can tend
to study them that way and temporal
features or how quickly these reshares
are propagating on the graph so I find
here is that we can predict Casta grow
really well even though just a
regression classifier to predict of a
cascade that reach 5 ratios will double
in size you find that performance is
robust independent of feature sets so
even without temporal features which do
the best on
our own we don't lose too much
inaccuracy so cascade growth is
predictable at least for five research
but what is the number of research we
observe increases what happens to
predictability as we observe more of a
cascade so how does prediction
performance change with K as number of
reshares increases so is it easier or
more difficult to predict whether the
Cascade of five ratios will grow beyond
10 measures ohmic a stay of 10 ratios
will grow beyond 20 Reacher's so in one
hand maybe you have more data in the
second task so the second one is easier
but at the same time the second is a
harder more complex question and that
you have to predict further into the
future so which is it what we find is
that as a cascade grows larger becomes
easier to predict if it will double and
these results demonstrate observing more
of a cascade while predicting further
into the future is easier than observing
observing a cascade early in its life
and predicting what you'll do next and
again what's nice about this approach is
that it allows us to continue to ask as
a cascade grows in size from small to
large what is going to continue doubling
but not only is cascade growth
predictable for instance you can also
predict as a cascade would be
structurally more or less viral and we
can also predict the Cascade recur or
come back so this was the individual
view of any social behavior from before
this might be the how the network view
looks like where posts comments views
and rumors transmitted a transmitted
from person the person also result in
these long range of far-reaching
Cascades Network so to conclude this
part of the talk here's the overall
summary of what we found so we found
that trolling is situational and then
the perp and that a person's mood and
context of a discussion can influence
them patrol meaning that ordinary people
can end up trolling under the right or
wrong circumstances we found a trolling
behavior can spread in the networks not
only through these effects but through
negative evaluations or downloading as
well finally looking while we'll be
installing cascades of bad behavior and
misinformation we looked at the spread
of rumours and of Cascades and find a
contrary to a probably
that need caskets are fundamentally
unpredictable that their scrotal growth
can be predicted so what's next right so
as I mentioned previously this part on
how to portion up votes is decreasing
over time is very interesting and one
where more research is needed as are
these observations due to cascades or
are they due to changing populations
right more generally how could we
predict the trajectory of a category of
a community moving forward
well community events to decline and how
long will that takes
but overall given all these results
right on any social behavior and let's
talk about studying the demise of
communities it might be easy to feel
kind of cynicism and despair about the
state of social media or social
computing but knowing the mechanisms of
anti-social behavior we also think about
building better systems that you with
such behavior instead encourage
pro-social behavior one important design
implication of our results is that
downloading is relatively toxic and on
in your communities so you might want to
prioritize designs that exclude it and
also because we have a better
understanding of how context needs to
people trolling here's an example of how
a context aware discussion platform that
use machine learning interventions might
encourage pro-social discourse for
example if we think about a user who
might be angry in the heat of the moment
maybe because they recently participated
in a heated discussion
you could delay post for some time you
might also think about how I might
introduce mechanisms to mediate
conversations so some recent works
showed how bot can be used sanctioned
badly behaving users on Twitter and
shown in this example
approaches such as this could help
manage flooding tempers highlight
constructive conversations and even
guide these conversations to and beyond
this I see several other promising
directions in the field of antisocial
computing and one is on both broadening
and deepening the scope of what any
social behavioral trolling means so we
talked about antisocial behavior in here
very generally but there are many
distinct types of it including what's
called salt puppetry right in this
example here we see two supposedly
different users complementing the right
of an article but it subsequently
revealed that they are actually the same
person so in a recent paper that I was
fortunate to be a part
of a wrister John who's somewhere in
this room yes we develop tools to
characterize and automatically identify
soft puppets in online discussions so
more broadly there are also a lot of
opportunities to continue develop
platforms that not only address trolling
but also other difficult challenges such
as polarization and misinformation and
at the same time we don't know very much
about how algorithms impact what people
see understanding what role these play
in propagating negative behavior or mean
can help but it's better quantify what
impact ranking has on what we do and
while we looked at how behaviors from
person to person
oh how cascade spread on Facebook it
also would be evaluating an even larger
picture approach and track cascades of
information or behavior at a larger
scale as you continue to evolve over
communities over very long periods of
time so while this talk was about any
social computing I think the methods
here extend beyond understanding bad
behavior
what I hope this research demonstrates
is that we can develop holistic
end-to-end approaches for analyzing and
building social systems right by
combining large-scale analysis of
experimentation you can make
generalizable observations that are
backed by experiments which establish
causality and which enable prediction
for example like the work on identifying
causes of trolling this approach also
allows us to look at both the big
picture interactions and that was
related to those between individuals
right for example a network theoretic
properties of networks of Cascades to
the mechanisms to the racially propagate
and importantly it also seeks to
leverage these findings about new
systems that better support our online
interactions so as a whole this research
shows how multi methods analyses allow
us to identify patterns in data verify
hypothesis hypotheses make predictions
and develop social systems and through
the work I've presented today on sort of
any social behavior non cascading
behavior I hope that I've shown how this
can be done in practice now we almost at
the end but I like to take some time to
thank everyone who helped me in one way
or another I think this is probably only
time I can do this publicly so I want to
do it now so to begin I like the
tank-tank
URI it's actually full of ideas
energy has helped me continuously push
my boundaries and that of others Michael
always positive and supportive was
encouraged me to explore so much
interesting work that unfortunately
cannot cover in this top john to whom I
owe my interest in social network all
things Lada one of my role models and
without whom many of these projects
wouldn't exist and of course James and
Jeff thank you for agreeing to be part
my orals committee Christian who have
worked with since I was an undergrad and
Dan who sparked my interest in human
centered research thank you to each and
every one of my collaborators a research
would not have been done without you and
thank you to all the people who I met in
grad school and made life a little bit
more colorful and to my family as well I
wouldn't be standing here without them
and finally to everyone in the assembly
HCI group and the snack group Stanford
VP GE Microsoft Research Facebook
Pinterest discuss for having supported
and continuing to support my research
and thank you for listening I'll take
any questions now yeah those vehicles
thanks ed affection um you you talked a
lot about the negative problems with
social discussions i will be slamming
and so on is any positive sizes like you
people get anything out of online
comments do you see people changing your
minds of using fda to just like get rid
of all these description i think i think
the approach to getting rid of all
discussion platforms is one that works
but it's also a bit short-sighted i
think one good example of this is there
is a subreddit and really call our
change my view that was a really good
paper out of Cornell they look at that
community and how people actually work
to actually try to change their minds
right in the right settings right there
are lots of different platforms
discussion platforms where discussions
don't end up in in flames right there
are lots of smaller places I think you
can imagine that there are discussions
where you imagine these things happen
and there are a lot of smaller ones
right as well
discussion is actually a lot more
positive right so I think discussions in
general are good because it's good to
talk to people and learn more about the
world and about different perspectives
but the same time we need the right
interventions to kind of make this
happen and so without these interactions
these interventions these kinds of I
guess having discussions might actually
make things a bit worse depending as
well so really I think it depends a lot
on like system designers and it's up to
so some designers to kind of figure out
like what what discussion platforms what
discussion mechanisms worked for them
and also up to us to try to really
remember that we are talking to other
human beings online as well yeah like
getting down would cause me to go down
controller I want you learning how to
occurs from the perspective of the color
right those buttons don't actually send
you a notification or something when you
get down put it right so is it like in
conjunction with another comment or some
other event is causing coming back and
that they can tell employees right so I
think there are kinds of a few
components this right one is definitely
the fact that discussion flapless don't
actually notify people if they've been
downloaded only way you know is by going
back to your comment and seeing how the
how the elbows in double exchange I
think maybe some of us have experiences
in red as far where you go make a
comment then we keep refreshing the page
to see if people have uploaded or
downloaded us and seeing how the score
changes over time I think maybe this
might be one part of what happens right
that when you see this happen maybe you
start asking like oh this this community
is like terrible right I I don't I don't
agree what they're doing here I wrote
such a good comment and then people are
just like attacking me and downloading
me who are these what is ridiculous
people right I'm going to stop caring
about what I write and I'm going to just
start writing worse and that might be a
reason why people start to care less
about why they right after getting
downloaded right because it really feels
bad right even if you tell yourself you
should not take it personally you still
do a part of the process definitely like
the different conversations that people
take part in so again like you see
downloading you might be involved in a
heated discussion right we're
downloading does take place and so this
might also be another factor that
influences you the work to write worse
in the future when you just get into a
heated discussion and
then you just write worse and worse as
you start to argue of people other
people in the same threat and of course
again we see these effects propagate
across different discussions different
threads so again this is not all of
what's happening yep
yes some of the future work we pop it up
discussed the Taliban current East our
sparrows are beginning but I've also
looked into our interest in looking into
how we can reverse the now response
location I can you turn it on very cold
I think I think really that is that is
one interesting thing that we have not
looked at so far that I didn't I was
thinking about putting to future wave I
didn't maybe I should have so that's
actually a small proportion of users
right if I remember Carney to select
about 10% of users who start out like
Behaving Badly music communities right
where all their posts get deleted by
madres but and after a while they
actually start to get better right so I
think this is one one one part of the
data that we can look at and try to
better understand like how do we stop
people from behaving badly over time I
think that's one approach that we can
take and definitely I think the the goal
of all this research is not to give
people the tools to destroy
conversations but instead to figure out
here are the things that make things bad
and here's how we can prevent them or do
the reverse yeah yeah you observed
negative dynamics negative cars like
that might be positive true about
positive comments as well like how do we
sometimes have become ungrounded ly
excited and fanatic about things that
they shouldn't deserve that of support
and just and I think that's actually a
very interesting interesting point of
view about the effects of hype I think
right now I think the challenge is that
it's hard to kind of quantify when hype
happens but I think that's actually a
very interesting of direction for future
work we did on the other hand look at
positive comments and seeing whether up
voting can kind of like encourage more
voting and the answer is that no it does
not but maybe hype is different and I
imagine maybe the mechanisms there is
different like if you're like very
excited personally excited about
something if you see the text and see
some people getting excited
think they're looking at the language of
what people write try to identify when
things happen when emotions are changing
very rapidly from like maybe neutral to
very positive I think that's actually
very interesting a pro direction from
York thank you yeah yeah the Britney
looking do that and most users of
anonymous and would've anonymity gave to
ones
willingness to be you know socially
disruptive well as opposed to not quick
like a self is not economic competence
yes so I think that anonymity definitely
has an effect on how people choose to
behave because when you're anonymous
you're more disinhibited right so you
feel they're less consequences for our
actions as you mentioned but at the same
time I think also that this this can
help another week another video
not having anonymity is good right do
you like compare like how much trolling
there is unlike platforms with or
without it but also things that on
Facebook swell if you look at the public
discussions there they're not the best
things you want to read anyway
and they'll keep on using their real
names and you can see if their photos
there as well and they still decide to
post these these comments right and so I
think that that may solve some of the
some of it but not all of it and on the
other hand I think anonymity is really
available to have in many discussion
platforms especially when you're talking
about things but you don't want to
review your identity to people so I
think that maybe solve the problem to
some extent for some groups of people
and in some cases maybe public comments
should always be non-anonymous to use a
real names there but there definitely
cases but it's important to be anonymous
to have a separate identity right just
to for your own safety
yes yeah so you can study beyond social
failure of this individual restaurant
you think that the finding generalized
the societal result they kind of Geneva
Paris
so I think me I think I don't want to go
as far as making the claim that it
applies to everyone I think I think visa
this is strong evidence that that might
be the case that we looked at many
different communities and try and
replicate these findings across many of
them we can a lot of these are news
communities and we try to also bolster
this by using experiments on Mechanical
Turk you're like each of these methods
by themselves have limitations right and
the populations that you're studying in
the specific intervention that you're
testing right and then the observations
that you're making I think like all
together
I think this tries to at least get
closer to being able to argue that this
does happen at large scale and that it
generally applies to most people not
everyone but in general in aggregate to
most people
yeah I think if anyone is interested in
polarization I think that is a really
interesting and very very challenging
problem to study just because we I think
it's just a very hard problem and very
difficult to change people's minds I
think probably even more valuable today
than ever before so yeah after you talk
about that afterwards - yeah I really
like the expensive and turning people
into salt and maybe if you have already
or if it would be possible to do an
apology it is pretty similar experiment
where you count what people and see if
that like you experimental II done with
people right on interfere in the world
and you look at the because I'm a little
unconditional placated with people are
different together right I think I think
definitely that that is in the works
right now we're also working on a paper
where we try to look at what happens
when communities when W introduce in the
community so there we have a natural
experiment where you can identify the
effects of downloading yes good point
think yeah I mean there are lots of
limitations to allow the work that
percentage here we try our best to do
what we can but again like it's there
are still going need limitation so as
you mentioned go so yeah
you know just this surprised by this
factor in the section you did on the
schematic about the show that if someone
gets a negative or negative evaluation
that not only that's interesting
colleges high-quality decrease but in
there is a sense of community member
regions by this person come true is
going to dump with them is that census
is just use the phrasing that there will
be two such as our discussion forum like
CNI presumably you don't remember the
names of the other commenters honestly
an article do you think it it's really
like the community memory or is it just
that take person gets more pissed off
and write differently in a way that
might not be captured by your text
quality metrics so I think definitely
though those two things are going to
play a role and I think we can we can
exactly tease apart all these factors
now this community perception the
strength of this measure actually is
strongest like within discussions right
so you look at what people write
subsequently its strongest there we look
across discussions where you might not
remember like who's there anymore
I think this effect is weaker but it's
still access and it is significant there
so I think it's probably a combination
of what you mentioned as well that maybe
text quality is not going to capture as
much as we hope that it would that it is
but in general we tried our best to kind
of validate that measure and show that
in general it tries to capture most
things but but again I might miss like
these kind of corner cases we're going
to be try to kind of show how how people
kind of like behave worse in communities
and again I show that this increases
their decreases last year there's a lot
of that's not more detail in the paper
that I'm glossing over right now and a
lot of complications that I'm extracting
away in this presentation but happy to
talk more about this afterwards
okay let's thank Justin
you